All right, it's time for this week's hatred
mail. It's an interesting one this week, but
first a reminder, what is hatred? Mail.
We're so old, right? It's wrong.
Hey, tread [inaudible] written by Patriots
who hate David Pakman because America and
because freedom.
Okay, so hatred. Mail is often conspiratorial,
but there's something charming about this
one because it is so nuanced. It's like those
Russian matryoshka dolls, the the successively
smaller and smaller dolls. Uh, take a listen
to this week's Patriot mail.
I knew Pacman was an undercover Bernie shill
pretending to shill for Warren. Tell me, David
Pakman isn't a shill the for the evil and
powerful. This is exactly the kind of thing
his shill would do though. Pretend to be for
Bernie. Get our hopes up that Bernie is winning.
Then when the moment comes, you tell us that
Warren or Biden Hackman's favorite, by the
way, caught back up. Tulsi has 61% approval
in her district and her challenger as a corporate
shill. Yeah, I'd like to bet my money on Tulsi.
Once again, Pacman shows his true colors as
another corporate sellout. I
kind of love the nuance. I'm actually a Bernie
shill, but what I've done in order to hide
that is to pretend to be a shill for Warren
so that no one notices that. While I appear
to be shilling for Elizabeth Warren, I'm actually
secretly Schilling for Bernie Sanders because
that's actually my priority. How about I call
it like I see it? Uh, there's no hidden agenda
at all. Sometimes I will agree with what one
candidate says does, proposes or believes.
Sometimes I might disagree with that exact
same candidate and there is no shadow agenda
or strategy where I am trying to, uh, create
an environment in which my true preference
will be hidden but still be able to influence
my audience in that direction. I've told everybody
I'm a Bernie Warren guy. I think by the time
Massachusetts votes, the primary will by and
large be decided. I will eventually tell you
who I vote for and I won't participate in
the types of attacks on the progressive candidates
beyond critiquing policy.
I disagree with which of course I do that
has the potential to hurt the democratic chances
in November of 2020. That's my position. I'm
not hiding the agenda from you. That is my
agenda. I have one. Uh, but it is not to secretly
show for one candidate by pretending to fill
for another fight. Hatred, autism by uh, using
the coupon code hatred at 40. If you get a
membership@joinpacman.com and use the coupon
code H a T R I, O T four zero, you'll save
40% and it's like a middle finger to the hatreds.